hi and welcome to my video series of bio
techniques explaining five minutes where
I explain a bio technique in less than
five minutes or so so if you haven't you
subscribe my channel hit that subscribe
button and why are you waiting for
today's installment we're going to talk
about radio a mini essay which uses
antibodies to detect and quantitate the
amount of antigen in a sample here is a
multi wall plate where you would add
your sample that need to be analyzed and
where you want to know about its
concentration so let's look at one will
to understand the principle bit more
details so let's say you want to detect
an antigen a and you ask the question
this antigen a is present in the patient
sample or not so first you coat the will
with antibody against a or an T a let's
call it and now you put radio labeled
antigen a or let's say any other kind of
labeled antigen a and lastly you put
patient's serum derived or patient serum
or patient's body fluid which expected
to have antigen a and that's a question
whether the patient serum has antigen a
or not that's the thing that you want to
detect so simply radio a mineral say
relies on the principle of comparative
finding where a radioactive antigen this
is a tracer would actually compete with
a non radioactive antigen to bind to
this particular antibody shown here now
if the patient sample has huge amount of
P's unleveled antigens then
radioactivity would be decreased
progressively with the increase of the
antigen concentration and a nice plot
could be derived from that which is a
linear regression from this by
extrapolating this poor plot we can
understand the concentration of the
patient's sample where the antigen is
present and based on the standard curve
we can get accurate value of the
concentration so if you have a higher
concentration radioactivity would be
very low or radioactivity or the rate of
decrease of radioactivity would be quite
high and if we have a low
antigen in the patient sample
radioactivity won't fall that much so
depending upon how much percentage of
the radioactivity is reduced gives us a
quantitative measure about the amount of
antigen present now let's say we have a
patient scenario of one and a patient
scenario two and both the cases as you
can see mission two has more antigen
present in its serum so as expected
after washing these things what you
would see is the second cases the
radioactivity would really fall because
there most of the labeled antigens are
replaced by unlabeled antigen why is so
because unlabeled antigen was higher in
concentration where whereas in the
patient one the unleavened unlabeled
antigen was not so much as a result not
too much of radioactivity is going down
and there are a few radioactive antigens
which is still labeling the antibody so
based on these observations we can
clearly understand a quantitative
measurement about patient sample so
let's look at the downside and the
upside of this process it is very
sensitive process and it is possible to
detect as low as few picograms of
antigen provided your antibody is super
good and but the downside is it use
radioactive materials which would be
hazardous now application of this radium
in USA is pretty broad spectrum so it
can be used for drug detection from
blood samples blood bank screening for
contaminants such as a hemorrhage is B
virus so it can really scan forever it
is B antigens in a blood bag sample
which ensures you don't have a
contaminated blood in the blood bank it
can be used to detect cancer biomarkers
which are soluble
other than that measuring hormone levels
measurement of disease associated
antigen levels all of these usage can be
done by determining si you can will also
be used to detect certain vitamins and
other metabolites provided specific
antibody is present against them because
the whole process is dependent upon
antigen-antibody interaction so you
really need specificity of interaction
between antigen and antibody otherwise
this whole
process won't work so that is pretty
much about radium USA and we learned
about what is a usage of this thing and
the sensitivity of the technique is
great which makes it still a technique
to be used today in the medical research
so I hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you
[Music]